في نفس السياق افاد مراسلنا بان مجلس
الحرب الاسرائيلي سوف يلتئم غدا لبحث صفقه
جديده لتبادل الاسرى وكانت هيئه البث
الاسرائيليه قد كشفت ان وزير الدفاع يو اف
جلنت وعضو مجلس الحرب بن جانس رفض مشاركه
رئيس الحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو في مؤتمر
صحفي مشترك
اليوم ومعنا من تلبيب ينضم الينا مراسل
الجزيره الياس كرام يص دعنا في صوره ما
يجري من تصورات واختلافات بين اعضاء مجلس
الحرب الاسرائيلي بخصوص مستقبل هذه
الحرب واضح خديجه بان هنالك خلافات
وخلافات كبيره وعميقه حول سير العمليات
والمستقبل السياسي لما بعد الحرب في قطاع
غزه ورفض بيني جانس وزير الوزير في مجلس
الحرب ووزير الدفاع يوف جلنت مشا شاركت
بنيمين نتنياهو هذا المساء في تصريح صحفي
وفي مؤتمر صحفي يدل على عمق هذا الخلاف
بين الاطراف لا سما ما نشر في الايام
الماضيه عن ان رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو منع وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يوف
جلان من عقد اجتماع
بمشاركه رئيس المساد ديدي برنياع لتناول
مساله وملف الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين
في داخل قطاع غزه وكان واضحا بان هنالك ك
خلافات في الرؤى ما بين جالانت وما بين
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
منذ اليوم الاول للحرب ليس فقط في كل ما
يتعلق بكيفيه اداره المعركه في قطاع غزه
انما ايضا في الرؤيه بالتعاطي مع ما يجري
على الحدود الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه وكنا
نعرف بان جلنت هو من كان
يقود موقفا بضروره القيام بحرب استباقيه
خاطفه ضد حزب الله في لبنان وبنيامين
نتنياهو منعه من ذلك وهناك هنالك ايضا
الخلافات ما بين بنيامين نتنياهو والوزير
بيني جانس فيما يتعلق بالرؤيه ما بعد
الحرب من الذي سيتولى زمام الامور واداره
شؤون قطاع غزه واضح بان بيني جانز كان
يرغب بعقد على الاقل اجتماع يدرس هذه
المساله ويبحث هذه المساله لكن بنيامين
نتنياهو رضخ للجناح المتطرف الفاشي في
حكومته المتمثل بوزير الماليه بت ال
سموتريتش ووزير الامن القومي ايتمار بنفير
وفضل الا يغضبه ما على ان يناقش هذه
المساله الهامه وهي مطلب ايضا امريكي مطلب
من الاداره الامريكيه التي تريد للحكومه
الاسرائيليه ان تحدد استراتيجيه واضحه
فيما يتعلق برؤيه ما بعد الحرب ومن
سيدير القطاع من الناحيه المدنيه على
الاقل لذلك واضح بان هذه الخلافات بدات
تطفو على السطح لكن حتى الان بيني جانس لا
يهدد في الاستقاله من حكومه الطوارئ رغم
ان بنيامين نتنياهو يعرف بانه سياتي اليوم
الذي سينسحب فيه بين جانس من هذه الحكومه
لذلك نراه يتمسك ايضا في القاعده الشعبيه
لحكومته اليمينيه الضيقه بمعنى يتمسك
بشركائه اليمنيين المتطرفين على حساب ربما
الاطراف ال الاخرى من ناحيه ثانيه مجلس
الحرب الاسرائيلي يبدو انه سيلتئم غدا
لمناقشه افكار جديده تتعلق بصفقه جديده
لتبادل الاسرى الاسرائيليين المحتجزين
داخل قطاع غزه هنالك نوع من التفاؤل على
الاقل من خلال بعض ما تنقله وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه عن مصادر مطلعه في هذا الشان
تفاؤل حذر حقيقه رغم ان المواقف لم تتغير
كثيرا بمعنى ان المقاومه الفلسطينيه ما
زالت تصر على وقف تام لاطلاق النار في
قطاع غزه وانسحاب القوات الاسرائيليه الى
خارج السياج الامني فيما تقول اسرائيل
بانها لن توافق البته عن اي حديث لوقف
اطلاق النار ووقف الحرب او اي انسحاب من
قطاع غزه لكن المطروح حاليا هو ربما صفقه
مرحليه تعود على نفس الشروط التي كانت
اسرائيل طالبت فيها في الاسابيع الماضيه
وهي ان تكون هذه المرحله تشمل بين 40 الى
50 من الاسر وبيني جان اذا كنت اسمعني
الياس اذا كان جالانت وبيني جانس يرفضان
حتى الظهور معه في مؤتمر صحفي يعني نتسا
غدا في في اجتماع مجلس الحرب هل سيحضران
سيغيبان ما الذي سيحدث
اذا لا هما هم سيحضران بدون ادنى شك واضح
بانهما سيحضران اجتماع مجلس الحرب على
اعتبار ان هذا المجلس هو المخول في اداره
شؤون الحرب وفي اداره الاهداف التي وضعتها
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لهذه الحرب بعنى
مساله القضاء على حركه حماس عسكريا
وسلطوية مساله استعاده المحتجزين
الاسرائيليين في داخل قطاع غزه الخلافات
موجوده لكنها لا تعكر حتى الان صفوى
العلاقات او على الاقل لا تعكر اتخاذ
القرارات فيما يتعلق بشؤون اداره الحرب
هنالك مواقف وتباين في المواقف وواضح بان
جلنت وبيني جانس لم يريدا مشاركه بنيامين
نتنياهو كموقف يعبر عن غضب يعبر عن موقف
لما فعله بنيامين نتنياهو في منع وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي بعقد اجتماع بهذا
الخصوص
بحضور الرئيس المساد ديدي برني لان واضح
بان بنيامين النياه يخوض خطا مختلف عن
رئيس المساق بالتعاطي مع مساله
اس العسري بمجلس الحرب وحكومه
ايضا هو خديجه الان مجلس الحرب هو مخول من
ناحيه الحكومه الا اسرائيليه بهيئتها
الكامله ومنن مجلس المجلس الوزاري المصغر
للشؤون السياسيه والامنيه في اسرائيل في
اداره شؤون الحرب لكن واضح بان ال الجناح
المتطرف في الحكومه الاسرائيليه وتحديدا
اتمار بنفير قالها صراحه بانه يجب حل مجلس
الحرب واعاده زمام المبادره وزمام القرار
الى المجلس الوزاري المصغر وربما ايضا الى
الهيئه العامه للحكومه الاسرائيليه على
اعتبار ان المجلس الحربي غير مخول في
التعاطي مع مساله ما بعد الحرب او مع
القضايا السياسيه والاستراتيجيه الكبرى
وان مجلس الحرب من وجهه نظر اتمار بنفير
هو يعني ينفذ القرارات وينفذ ما [__] به
هذا المجلس من الحكومه ال الحكومه بكامل
هيئتها من ناحيه والمجلس الوزاري المصغر
لكنه غير مخول بحسم قرارات تتعلق
بمستقبل قطاع غزه
والاستراتيجيه ال المتعلقه بهذا الامر